foreign
and welcome to Simply learn I hope you
guys are doing well staying safe in
today's session we'll be discussing some
top devops tools that you must know in
2023 now in the dynamic world of devops
straying abrush of the top tools is
essential for professionals seeking to
enhance their productivity and
efficiency so devops tools discussed in
this tutorial will cover a broad
spectrum of functionalities ranging from
Automation and containerization to
monitoring and project management
familiarity with these tools enables
professionals to streamline the
development and operations processes
improv collaboration and Achieve faster
more Reliable Software releases and much
more so without any further Ado let's
get started with today's topic now in a
world driven by rapid technological
advancements businesses are constantly
seeking ways to deliver software faster
and more efficiently enter devops the
dynamic philosophy that has
revolutionize the software development
and operations landscape devops is not
just a buzzword it's a game engineering
approach that Bridges the gap between
developers and operations team Foster
collaboration and enhancing the entire
software development life cycle now at
its core devops embodies a cultural
shift towards seamless integration and
continuous delivery a promotes a
collaborative environment where
developers system administrators quality
assurance professionals and other
stakeholders work together harmoniously
and promoting cross-functional
communication the devops and past teams
is streamlined processes automate
workflows and ultimately deliver high
quality software at an accelerated pace
having said that the demand for devops
professionals has overgrown in recent
years as more and more companies
adaptive practices to improve their
software development and delivery
processes so are you ready to advance
your professional career to the next
level taking our step-by-step simple
learn sports archet program in devops in
collaboration with IBM will help you
start your devops journey that will
prepare you for the devops engineer role
so in order to match your skill set
market demand this day of training
program is designed in collaboration
with caltex ctme and a cutting-edge
blended learning combines live online
day of certification classes with
interactive labs to give you a practical
experience this day of training program
will cover skills like devops
methodology continuous integration Day
Option Cloud infrastructure deployment
Automation and many more and along with
that you'll also get hands-on experience
with latest tools and techniques
including terraform Maven ansible Docker
Jenkins and much more so if you're
looking to pursue your career as a
devops engineer and acquire these skills
that will prepare you for your job
consider enrolling in this intensive
training program today we will leave the
link in the description box below so
make sure you check that out so let us
move ahead and proceed with our topic
today so the main question is what fuels
is devops Revolution now it's a powerful
collection of tools specifically
designed to support and amplify its
principles so these tools act as a
catalyst empowering teams to automate
tasks manage infrastructure efficiently
and monitor application performs
efficiently so without any further delay
let us directly jump into the top nine
noteworthy tools highlighting their
features benefits and significance that
have become synonymous with the devops
ecosystem in no particular order
so first on the list we have Jenkins now
Jenkins is an open source automation
server known for its extensive plug-in
ecosystem making it highly versatile and
customizable it facilitates continuous
integration and continuous delivery or
in short cacd pipelines automating the
built test and deployment processes
Jenkins enables team to internet code
frequently entering early detection of
issues and faster software releases
so let us now look at some of the key
features of their Jenkins firstly easy
installation and configuration Jenkins
has a user-friendly web interface that
simplifies installation configuration
and management of build jobs and
pipelines distributed build for
scalability now it's supposed to have
vast ecosystem of plugins for CMS
integration and it can distribute build
tasks across multiple nodes which helps
in paralyzing builds and reducing
overall build time especially in large
projects and finally extensible through
scripting languages like Ruby now
Jenkins provides extensibility through
scripting languages like groovy which is
a powerful and versatile language that
runs on the Java virtual machines or in
short jvm so by leveraging groovy
scripting capabilities Jenkins becomes
highly adaptable and customizable to
meet the specific requirements of
different development teams and projects
so those are some of the key features of
jetkins let us now move ahead and
discuss some of the benefits or
advantages of using Jenkins so firstly
we have enabled faster feedback and
quicker time to market now Jenkins
continuous integration capabilities
enable developers to merge their code
changes into a shared repository
regularly by doing so Jenkins
automatically triggers build and testing
processes to validate any kind of
changes this automates feedback loop
allows developers to receive quick
feedback on the quality of their code so
as a result issues and bugs can be
identified early in the development
cycle preventing the accumulation of
defects and reducing the time required
to fix them as discussed earlier it also
facilitates early issue detection and
reduce bug turnaround time now with
Jenkins running automated builds and
test every time new code is committed
potential issues and bugs are bought
early in the development process so by
detecting issues at an early stage
developers can address them promptly
before they propagate further into the
code base
and finally automates repetitive tasks
save time and effort now junkets
automates various tasks involved in the
software development life cycle using
through Stars such as building the code
running tests and deploying applications
by automating these repetitive and time
consuming tasks gen can saves developers
and operations significant amount of
time and efforts so that is what Jenkins
is all about it's a widely adopted in
the day of landscape due to its
flexibility and extensive plug-in
support and learning it will add a great
value to your array of skills so it's
ability to automate crcd processes and
integrate with various tools makes it a
crucial component of models of your
development and delivery Pipelines
second on the list we have Docker Docker
has revolutionized application
deployment with its continualization
approach it allows developers to package
applications and their dependencies into
lightweight isolated containers Docker
contains provide consistency across
different environments ensuring that
applications and consistently regardless
of the underlying infrastructure this
portability along with the rapid startup
times and efficient resource utilization
has made Docker a foundational tool and
DeVos practices so let us now discuss
some of the key features of Docker first
one is packaging applications and
dependencies into containers now Dockers
allows developer to package their
applications and all their dependencies
into a self-contained units called
containers and the process is known as
containerization now these containers
encapsulate the application code its
runtime various libraries and system
tools required to run the application by
doing so Docker ensures consistency
across different environments secondly
efficient resource utilization through
containerization now this lightweight
nature of containers allows for more
efficient resource utilization multiple
containers can run on a single fiscal
machine without the need for individual
OS instances it means that you can host
more applications and services on the
same Hardware than using the number of
servers needed and finally easy scaling
and management of containers Now
containerization simplifies application
scaling and management so when you need
to handle increased application load you
can quickly scale by running more
instances on the containerized
application on additional servers or
within a container orchestration
platform like kubernetes
so let us now talk about some of the
benefits of the docker tool now firstly
rapid deployment and scalability Docker
enables rapid deployment of application
Studios lightweight and containerized
approach when using Dockers developers
package their applications and
dependencies into containers which
encapsulate everything needed to run the
application so these containers are
portable and can be easily moved from
one environment to the other and next we
have the isolation of applications and
dependencies for improved security
Docker utilizes containerization to
isolate applications and the
dependencies from the ecosystem and
other containers each containers operate
in its own user space separate from
other containers providing a strong
level of isolation this isolation
prevents applications from affecting
each other and helps contain potential
security breaches within the confines of
the container and finally simplify
development to production workflow now
Docker streamlined the relevant
production workflow by providing
consistency between different
environments with Docker developers can
create containers that run the same way
in development testing and production
environments thereby reducing the
chances of unexpected issues arising
during the deployment
so Docker has become a Cornerstone of
modern day of practices it's upgraded to
streamline application deployment and
improved resource utilization has
transformed software development and
operations enabling faster and more
reliable application relevant
so that was all about Docker so let us
now move ahead and discuss the next tool
which is kubernets so next on the list
we have kubernetes kubernetes is an open
source container orchestration platform
that automates the deployment scaling
and management of containerized
applications it provides a robust
infrastructure for running and
coordinating containers across clusters
of machine making it easier to manage
large scale deployments devops teams can
easily deploy update and scale
applications facilating faster and more
Reliable Software delivery while
promoting collaboration and consistency
Clause development and operations
lifecycle through kubernetes so let us
look at some of the key features of it
automatic container deployment and
scaling now container orchestration
platform to the kubernetes provide
automatic container deployment and
scaling capabilities when deploying
applications on kubernets you can Define
the desired state of your application
using yaml files on declarative
configuration kubernetes then take care
of this ensuring that specified number
of container replicas is running at all
times service Discovery and load
balancing now kubernet enables faster
feedback and weaker time to Market in a
country rise environment multiple
instances of an application may be
running across different containers
making it challenging for clients or
other services to know the IP addresses
of all the running instances and
detecting and keeping tracking of the
locations of various services within the
container cluster and kubernetes for
example provides a built-in service
Discovery mechanism next we have
self-healing and auto restart of
containers now container orchestration
platform provides self-healing
capabilities to ensure that applications
are always available and responsive if a
container fails to do an application
crash or any other issues the
orchestration platform detects the
failure and automatically restarts the
failed container
so let us now move ahead and discuss
some of the benefits of using kubernetes
tool firstly it is scalable and highly
available application and it provides a
seeming repeat and provides a seamless
scaling of resources based on demand
next it has a simplified management of
containerization applications across
various clusters and finally automated
deployment and updates reducing minor
Intervention which further improves
resource utilization and optimization
overall kubernetes has emerged as the
industry standards for container
orchestration It's ability to automate
application deployment scaling and
management simplifies the complexities
of running contenderized applications at
scale making it a crucial tool for
devops practitioners
moving and let us discuss our next tool
which is ansible ansible is a powerful
automation tool that simplifies
configuration management application
deployment and orchestration it employs
a declarative language to Define desired
shared configuration making it easy to
manage and automate infrastructure tasks
ansible follows an agentless
architecture allowing it to work
efficiently across a wide range of
systems and environments so let us now
look at look at some of its features
firstly it's a declarative language for
defining infrastructure configuration
and it is also an agentless architecture
for easy deployment and management as we
discussed earlier now this is done
through a Playbook driven automation for
orchestration where extensive library of
modules for a wide range of tasks are
employed so let's now discuss some of
its benefits so firstly it's simplify
infrastructure management through
automation which increases the
operational efficiency with reduced
manual task and its identity nature
ensures that it has consistently and
predictability overall
and finally it supports a wide range of
infrastructure automation use cases and
with its agentless architecture it
allows easy integration with various
systems and environments so in a
nutshell ansible Simplicity flexibility
and ease of use have made it a popular
choice for automating infrastructure and
application deployment task Dev approach
an agentless architecture contribute to
efficient and streamline development
Workforce
so moving ahead the next tool on our
list is git is a distributed version
control system that has become a
fundamental tool for modern software
development practices it allows
developers to track changes collaborate
effectively and manage code base
efficiently gets decentralized
architecture ensures that developers can
work offline and merge changes
seamlessly across branches let us now
discuss with some of its key features
now its distributed version control
system has efficient collaboration with
various tools within the management of
the ecosystem of devops and it also has
an integration with various code hosting
platforms which is the branching and
merging capabilities for concurrent
development and finally it's support for
code reviews and collaboration workflows
which also gives a commit based tracking
of changes so these are some of the key
features of git so let us now discuss
some of the advantages ornic benefits of
using it so firstly it's easy tracking
and management of code changes which
ensure sufficient collaboration and
concurrent development within the
resource files and its ability to work
offline and merge changes seamlessly
will benefit a lot of devops Engineers
and finally it's easy integration with
other devops tools makes it a wonderful
to use to manage code versions track
changes and enable efficient
collaboration which is Revolution as a
software development so it has become a
essential tool for Version Control
facilitating effective collaboration and
enabling streamline devops workflows
so moving ahead the next tool on our
list is terraform now terraform is an
infrastructure as code or in short IEC
tool that allows teams to Define and
provision infrastructure resources in a
declarative manner it supports multiple
Cloud providers and enables consistent
and reproducible infrastructure
deployment terraforms declarative syntax
and State Management capabilities
simplify infrastructure provisioning and
configuration
let us now integrate some of its key
features firstly it provides multi-cloud
support for provisioning resources
across different providers its
infrastructure as code approach for
consistent and reproducible deployments
makes it a declarative Syntax for
defining infrastructure configurations
and finally automated resource
provisioning and dependency management
so some of its benefits are the
advantages of using terraform as its
simplified resource provisioning and
dependency management now terraform's
infrastructure as code approach supports
for multiple Cloud providers makes it an
essential tool for managing
infrastructure goods and collaboration
and Version Control for infrastructure
configurations as well and finally in
State Management for tracking
infrastructure changes which makes it a
beneficial tool for devops engineers
is used to Monitor and manage the health
and performance of the infrastructure
application and network resources it's a
comprehensive monitoring solution to
identify and resolve issues proactively
ensuring High availability and
reliability of systems so let us look
some of its key features firstly its
monitoring capabilities
secondly it's centralized configure
management and finally its even handling
and escalation tool so learning nagios
is also a crucial and beneficial if you
are just starting one day Ops Journey
so moving ahead let us now discuss our
next tool on our list which is Elk stack
now elk stack offers a comprehensive
solution for centralizing logs from
various applications and systems making
it easier for devops teams to monitor
troubleshoot and gain valuable insights
from their log data the elk stack
comprising elasticsearch log stats and
kibana provides a comprehensive log
management and Analysis platform it acts
as a distribution search and analytics
engine while log stack collects
processes and transform logs and finally
kibana offers a user-friendly interface
for visualizing and exploring data
so some of its key features including
real-time monitoring and alerting
scalable and efficient Lock storage and
retrieval and distributed searching
analytics to data visualization and
Exploration with cabana
let us look at some of its benefits so
firstly it's real-time monitoring for
proactive detectives repeat its
real-time log monitoring for proactive
issue detection with the help of
centralized log management and Analysis
Advanced log analytics was
troubleshooting and performance
optimization making it a scalable
architecture for handling large-scale
volumes of data and finally efficient
log storage and retrieval for compliance
and auditing purposes in a nutshell elk
stack has gained immense popularity for
its ability to handle log management and
Analysis its scale it empowers devops
teams with real-time insights into
application and infrastructure logs
facilitating effective troubleshooting
and performance optimization
well finally on the list we have jira
software jira is a widely used project
management tool that supports Agile
development methodologies it offers
robust features for planning tracking
and managing task issues and workflows
jiras customizable boats backlogs and
workflows impact teams to collaborate
effectively visualize and progress to
gain transparency into project statuses
with integration to various devops rules
jira facetate seamless tracking of
development activities enabling
continuous Improvement and efficient
project management
some of its key features are
customizable both workflows for project
management agile planning and estimation
features issue tracking and management
capabilities
and some of its benefits include
efficient task management and tracking
enhance collaboration and visibility
across various teams and integration
with various devops tools for stream and
workflows it also helps in reporting an
analytics for project insights and
performance measurement finally jira has
become a go-to tool for agile project
management in the devops ecosystem it's
upgraded to support agile methodologies
track task and integrate with other
devops rules makes it a valuable assets
for teams seeking efficient project
management and continuous Improvement so
learning it will add a great value to
Ariel skills again so these were some of
the top 9 Bay Ops rules that you must
know which will help you enhance and
accelerate your career in devops in
conclusion as the devops landscape
evolves these tools will continue to
play a pivotal role in driving
Innovation and empowering organizations
to deliver high quality software
products efficiently
staying ahead in your career requires
continuous learning and upskilling
whether you're a student aiming to learn
today's top skills or a working
professional looking to advance your
career we've got you covered explore our
impressive catalog of certification
programs in Cutting Edge domains
including data science cloud computing
cyber security AI machine learning or
digital marketing designed in
collaboration with leading universities
and top corporations and delivered by
industry experts choose any of our
programs and set yourself on the path to
Career Success click the link in the
description to know more
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here
foreign